a lot of women commented on the little skit that I did like oh
I can't believe I did that
blah blah blah like this
do not beat yourself up
it's not your fault when you get involved with somebody like that
they fucking manipulated you
they used their children as a fucking tool
to get you to use your heart and empathy and be there
you what you did what you thought was a good thing
then in Hindsay
you're able to look back and say
gosh that was silly
I shouldn't have done that
I don't know why I participated in that way
so you have growth
so don't beat yourself up over something you did in the past
because that's not gonna serve you in the future
and all you can do is just be a vocal voice to help
women never make that mistake again
so thank you for adding to the conversation
thank you for validating that yes
there are women that gets trapped in these relationships
and pay their child support
and none of them are stupid
they're being abused